and you and Ken are still close friends
yeah super I mean I you know I love him
dearly he's like Isn't that cool I mean
I have some of those from from working
with people in the past not a lot I
don't I don't have a lot you know you
don't have a lot like you could become
very bonded with a lot of folks on set
and then you know kiss kiss goodbye yeah
just and it's not it isn't it seems to
the outside world to be disingenuous it
kind of it isn't you really do care
about them while you're working but you
don't stay connected right uh yeah I I
and I worked with piano I worked with
him on a movie called Sweet November for
a couple weeks I remember that movie and
he was this I played a transvestite and
he was awesome the sweetest I mean I I
Rave about him he is just like I was
like can I call you can too and he's
like you can call me whatever
you know whatever you like and he was
just so sweet and it was like it was so
humbling that such a huge movie star is
you know you hope that they're cool you
hope and sometimes they're not yeah your
heroes are not like but he genuinely I
feel like that yeah he's he is a
genuinely good guy but you know it's
it's we came up doing theater yeah we
came from crazy artists families we both
love good playwriting and good novels
and we just have a lot in common off
screen right
um but I'm you know I'm happy that he's
kept his sanity through the Journey that
one has were you surprised that he
wanted to do the third installment no
because we all developed it together
um so you were like it was a great
process we were having a barbecue at my
house the night Kristen had pitched it
to us so we're just all we've all been
friends forever wow so we were just at
my place eating steak that I had cooked
and Chris and I were like we got an idea
for and that was a dozen years before we
made it so it tells you how hard it
tells you like how little interest there
is in Hollywood for Bill and Ted movies
usually that's crazy so yeah did you
really were you at first when you first
kind of pitched it where you're like ah
you come on no it's kind of the inverse
because those guys don't none of us
um
more of the mindset that we were ever
gonna make a third so it was not joking
that it was almost like we have this
idea
for how to bring the guys back if
anybody wanted to bring them back and we
actually all thought it was a great idea
it was a sort of like a Christmas carol
thing of just like what if Bill and Ted
you just come in on them right now in
their lives and they are exactly the age
they're at and their dads and they're
not trying to be 16 and they're failures
and they have to go find the song they
were supposed to write in all these
different iterations of space time
and we were like that's a great idea
because it's you know you must be a good
actor greedily the first thing you think
is like can I actually play this right
yeah when you hear an idea like is this
do it like can I do this without oh
making a complete ass of myself yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah like it's playable
right because I just get to be me I
don't have to try to be bill at 16 or
whatever
um it's ludicrous and it has heart and
so I think we thought look if we can
pull it off and we all produced it so it
wasn't like we all then had to go to
work and like you know is it easy for
you to jump back into your character and
sink back with piano uh sync back with
Keanu yes jump back into character did
actually take an enormous amount of work
but it was fun but it wasn't easy per se
what did you do did you have to like
just watch for like a year I didn't
actually I was afraid I'd mimic myself
too much but I did a lot of a lot of
physical work just trying to find this
guy's body they're strange guys did you
make yourself laugh yes did you laugh on
set together constantly constantly it's
clowning who makes who laugh more uh I
don't know I don't want to be immodest
and say I make Keanu laugh more because
I laughed my ass off the whole time but
at the end of the first week we looked
at each other and we were like because
we hadn't acted together in so long we
just hang out it was like it's really
fun
acting together we really enjoyed it
yeah we just rip we finish each other's
sentences it's just it's just it's like
being in a band where you like where you
Groove is he sort of like Uncle Keanu to
your kids oh yeah yeah they all know him
yeah he comes and visits yeah yeah it's
always fun to sort of watch them get old
enough to realize who he is because they
never have no [ __ ] idea otherwise
only get to a certain age they're like
oh [ __ ] it's that guy oh really but then
he's been around like forever too late
thank you